-It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
[ Playing "Some Like It Hot" ]
♪ We ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ Tweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets.
We're all going to vote
on whether you like each one
or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
Yeah, you can vote
for all of these.
You can vote for none of them,
whatever you want,
and we'll see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have your clickers, too.
-Click away.
-Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out live
on the show,
so that you can all like it
and we tweet it.
[ Ahhs ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright, you guys ready
for this? Here we go.
The first tweet is...
[ Laughter ]
[ The Roots playing
jaunty tune ]
I like that one.
-I like that.
-Yeah. The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Whoa!
Not bad!
[ Rimshot ]
Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Alright!
-Alright.
That's not bad.
Alright,
let's try this next one.
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
What's it been,
like 100 years, 200 years?
-Every every hospital meal
has Jell-O.
-That's all they have.
"Sorry, the only thing
we can get you for dessert
is Jell-O."
-That's it.
-I love Jell-O.
-I love J.Lo and I love J.Lo.
-Yeah.
-Yeah! Yeah!
-Let's see the results
right here.
[ Drumroll ]
-Ooh.
-Oh.
[ Rimshot ]
-105.
-You know,
when I was in high school,
I remember I started to eat
Jell-O all the time,
just to make myself enjoy it,
like to make it
my favorite dessert,
[ Laughter ]
because --
because I knew that, one day,
I might be on my deathbed
in the hospital
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-and they're going to go,
"Sorry, Mr. Fallon,
we can't feed you anything.
The only thing we can give you
is Jell-O."
[ Laughter ]
And you see my heart rate
start going
-Beep!
-doot!
[ Laughter ]
-Beep! Beep beep beep!
-Let's go to this next one here.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-Wow.
-I do.
-Yeah.
-Cancel it.
-I'm going to say yes.
-It's actually not bad.
Tariq, you like that?
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
-That's a person
after my own heart.
-Let's see the results here.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-144.
-Whoo!
-144, that's a gross, baby.
-I like that.
That one's going to be
the winner, I think.
-That's 12 dozen, man.
-Oh, I like this one.
This one's pretty good, too.
-Ooh, what's this one, Number 4?
-Alright, ready?
Next up, it says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
It just doesn't work.
-Yeah.
-We should delete it
from all phrases.
Just 2023,
the phrase calm down is dead.
-I'll tell you to calm down!
-Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
It never works.
Let's see the results here.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
[ Rimshot ]
-176!
-Wow!
-Dang, J!
-There's no way.
There's no way
that's going to be --
-176.
-That's almost 100%.
-Only one dozen
people didn't vote.
-That's fantastic, guys.
I don't think you'll top it,
but I'll read the last one,
just in case,
because I think it's funny.
This last one is...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on.
Come on, everybody!
Come on, let's give it 100%!
[ Laughter ]
Alright, I think we made our
decision right here, alright.
Everyone stop voting right here.
Let's see the results
right here.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, that's it!
We have a winner!
Looks like it is
[ Rimshot ]
Number 4 is the one! Alright!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
you give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Christoph Waltz. Wall-tz.
[ Cheering and applause ]